Was ist das?
Das ist ein Buch.
Ist das eine Lampe?
Nein, das ist keine Lampe.
Das ist ein Glas.
Ist das ein Bett?
Nein, das ist kein Bett.
Das ist ein Sofa.
Wer ist das?
Das ist Nicole.
Sie kommt aus Lausanne.
Ist das dein Freund?
Nein, das ist nicht mein Freund.
Hast du eine Freundin?
Nein, ich habe keine Freundin.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, ich habe keine Kinder.
Ja, ich habe eine Tochter.
Sprechen Sie bitte langsam.
Was bedeutet Postleitzahl?
Wie schreibt man das?
Kannst du das bitte buchstabieren?
Können Sie das bitte buchstabieren?
Ich verstehe kein Schweizerdeutsch.
Sprechen Sie bitte Hochdeutsch.
Kannst du das bitte wiederholen?
Können Sie das bitte wiederholen?
Hier ist ein Schlüssel.
Ist das dein Schlüssel?
Nein, das ist nicht mein Schlüssel.
Welche Farbe hat der Schlüssel?
Er ist blau.
Hier ist eine Jacke.
Ist das deine Jacke?
Nein, das ist nicht meine Jacke.
Welche Farbe hat die Jacke?
Sie ist rot.
Hier ist ein Handy.
Ist das dein Handy?
Nein, das ist nicht mein Handy.
Welche Farbe hat das Handy?
Es ist schwarz.
grün
süss
das Buch - die Bücher
der Schüler - die Schüler
der Stuhl - die Stühle
März
später
das Land - die Länder
der Vater - die Väter
das Blatt - die Blätter
zwölf
hören
der Sohn - die Söhne
die Tochter - die Töchter
das Wort - die Wörter